es una escena inhabitual en kirguistán
una manifestación pacífica en el corazón
de biskek la capital cientos de personas
piden cuentas al gobierno por las
recientes tensiones en la frontera con
tayikistán que dejan decenas de muertos
en el lado kirguís y heridos en ambos
lados los manifestantes exigen el cese
de las hostilidades y el permiso para
llevar ayuda humanitaria a la frontera
estamos a el objetivo de esta acción no
es la guerra no tenemos armas no
queremos luchar solo queremos ir a
ayudar a la gente los que tuvieron que
huir a través de los campos necesitan
comida no queremos obstaculizar en
absoluto el trabajo de los militares los
dos países comparten cerca de mil
kilómetros de fronteras que aún no están
claramente definidas este enredo
territorial es el origen de las nuevas
tensiones la región de batken es una de
las provincias disputadas por los
kirguises y tayikos cada parte acusa a
la otra de bombardear a su vecino por el
momento la presión parece haber
disminuido gracias a la firma de un alto
el fuego tras una reunión entre los
jefes de estado de ambos países en la
cumbre de la organización relación de
shanghái en los wikis tan estas
tensiones son una herencia de la era
soviética en aquella época las fronteras
no tenían en cuenta las realidades
geográficas y étnicas dejando en algunos
lugares enclaves tayikos en territorio
kirguís el año pasado ya estuvo marcado
por los enfrentamientos entre ambos
países con un saldo de al menos 50
muertos